how are you doing sir i'm doing great
how are you doing good thanks i want to
start by asking uh having previously
played a musician in florence foster
jenkins were you a bit hesitant to play
at a accompanist conductor uh for this
film
yeah i thought it was kind of funny
actually that that happened again
like this strange
trio of oddities again in the world of
opera an accompaniment accompaniment uh
it yeah it seemed almost like the dark
underbelly to florence foster jenkins so
i only was worried that leias might
think oh i can't have you do that kind
of thing again i mean it's obviously
couldn't be farther from from that movie
but uh
but i don't even know if he had seen
from his foster jenkins so that that
that was a you know a helpful little
thing that happened there but yeah it is
an odd coincidence
i was curious how many takes did you
have to do in the scene it's a long take
where the camera's rotating around you
and you're speaking directly to the
audience it's really striking scene and
i was curious about how it came together
we did about
24
takes i think was how many uh ultimately
and they were all
mostly complete so it wasn't like whoops
uh you know something went wrong
um
it was the nuance of it uh
that
i that took that time and leo's um
he's in some ways he works as a
choreographer i think that's i think
adam
may have said that at one point and it
really did feel like that sometimes and
other times it was very
you know we would talk more emotionally
about what was going on and a lot of
times we just wouldn't talk at all but
um but in that scene he it was really
really specific so he would talk about
when the camera was behind me and it
comes around he wanted my eyes to be
closed and then he wanted them to open
on this line and that's when the tears
should come or don't keep your mouth
open after you say this or you say like
you know
he's like you put a pause in the middle
of this sentence
and i was like yeah like that was
unfortunate
everything else was so good
i was like oh like i didn't he heard it
and saw it all in his head so and i
didn't mind it i i found it to be you
know he's brilliant
i wanted to be
you know a piece of clay for him to and
then just try to try to achieve it and
uh
and then you see it and you're like wow
it i mean
he pulled off something pretty
spectacular in that in that shot i think
was that the most difficult scene for
you to film it's hard to say they were
all for the most part very challenging
um that had its own challenges which was
one it was one of the first things that
we shot
um and there was a real despair
to that
soliloquy that laos really wanted to see
and then of course just the element of
trying to conduct a 50-60 piece
orchestra and the technical part of it
and
um
so that was that had its own challenges
that
getting
drown and singing underwater um is
another challenge and uh operating a
puppet and playing the piano i mean they
all had their own obstacles but i was
always excited because i knew that laos
could see it and i knew that when you he
asked for the impossible he was not
necessarily always hoping that he would
maybe he was but that he would literally
get it it's like he if somebody ties you
up and restrains you it's like what kind
how can you creatively
get out of this or what can you come
close how close can you come to
accomplishing it and sometimes that's
the most
creative situation is those
those limitations that kind of friction
so
i love that he was always asking for
something that didn't seem humanly
possible but uh yeah they all had their
their unique challenges
well speaking of those limitations i
mean what was it like working with the
puppet annette
because if if acting is reacting how do
you sort of you know make your
performance come alive against a puppet
well i thought her reactions were
spectacular to me but i don't know uh
mine mine maybe not so much yeah well i
it is and it isn't i i mean
there's
it's amazing how much we really as
people can project onto
something and uh
you know there's that uh
what's that old uh
experiment they do like with film where
they would show people the the same
shots but edited in different sequences
and people would tell their own stories
that they would think that they had been
swapped out we're really bringing a lot
of
our own
bag issue but so i feel like
you're right i mean it isn't a human but
at the same time there was a there was
this tenderness that existed there and
partially because i had to take over the
controls sometimes of this puppet that
these two
brilliant people romulus and estelle
were the puppeteers names they created
this creature
and now i had to look after it much like
i did in the story so it kind of lent
itself there was like i had to give life
to this
being um
and i don't know i found it oddly
uh
uh oddly um
profound and moving actually uh and
it it is strange i don't know if it
would be like that with every puppet um
but she was a pretty uh spectacular one
were you a fan of sparks music before
signing on to this film
i had
heard about them like in many ways sort
of vet their legacy of like oh this is
your favorite band's favorite band that
you haven't heard of or you know so i
knew of them but i i did a deep dive
once i
once i got my hands on the script i
didn't have the part yet but um but then
i kept finding that i was like it's like
i listened to kimono in my house and i
thought oh this is amazing this album
and they're like a glam
prog band and then you listen to like
some of their later albums some like
indiscreet and it's like this like
baroque pop and you hear like
electronica and you hear
it's i realize they're just more than 20
plus albums there's no way to define
them which is i think makes them
so fascinating um but they're just the
sheer volume and and i i just think that
the layers that they're always operating
that the pop songs that they're
deceptively
poppy and then you realize wow there's
something dark here so i'm i'm i think
they're incredible the movie has a bit
of that quality i think yeah
you mentioned sort of the challenge of
having to sing underwater what was it
like staging that fight scene with adam
driver and sort of putting that all
together uh it was another that you know
it's like as choreographed as leos could
be sometimes like in the conducting
scene sometimes there was
there was a real you know looseness of
laissez faire kind of oh yeah so i know
i want you to fall into this table and
there was a stunt coordinator there who
worked with jean-claude van damme and i
thought why is he i thought maybe he was
going to step in for me because i'm
often compared to the muscles from
brussels but uh but he was just there to
talk and then he left and then so there
was a lot of these like you know
you have to hit this mark and that mark
but between falling on the table and
getting to the pool
let's say there was a lot of freedom and
so
that's when you're you know you're just
so
lucky to be working with someone as
brilliant and present as adam because uh
it became kind of like a dance and it
was different
it was different every take um
but uh but also you know that some of
that fear is is real and you can use it
because
you know there's a little bit of a
danger to all that um
and i think in the movie too you feel
all it always feels a little
like there's like an electric kind of
danger to everything
we the the big bang theory concluded
about two years ago and i was just
curious what your thoughts are on how
the show ended and if you were happy
with the end of howard's story
oh uh
it's been so long um
i
well i was happy with the way the show
ended i mean i i feel like everyone's
always gonna have some you know
complaint or something that feels
unsatisfied i think in some way and or
love this element of that but i um which
is good because people feel connected to
these characters and
you know there's a lot of opinions but i
might yeah for me i mean i guess i it
would have been interesting i feel like
if he got to meet his father i i that
was something i always thought might
happen and
um
and it didn't but you know i guess
there's also
in some ways characters live on you know
i think in people's minds after
the story ends so
it's good to leave a little bit to the
imagination
one more thing about uh annette i was
here you've talked a little bit about
sort of working with leos in terms of
how things can be so choreographed but
then other times he is gives you a lot
of freedom what was the overall
experience like of working with him on
this film
it was heavenly i honestly i
um
i would
do anything to work with him again i i
think that
there's
there's i really feel like trust has to
be a fundamental part of the equation
when you're working as an actor with
anybody but as an actor with your
director and if you trust them
then you can really
experiment and he's very experimental uh
even in all that choreography i never
felt confined i like the
i like that friction i like somebody
like giving you lanes and you have to
find
your own way of expressing yourself in
that those parameters because there's
always something it's always some kind
of framework you're in so i i mean if
you can i mean his body of work is so
exceptional so i i
how could you how could you have anybody
that you you trust more um and then
every it was every day was like
what is he going to throw at us and that
really keeps an energy on the set like
oh we're running through a forest or
it's going to be in one shot or he wants
you to go under water while you're doing
this or you know whatever it might be
and
that keeps things um alive and exciting
so yeah i
i think it's a that that playfulness is
um
is crucial
well thank you so much congrats on the
film and i hope you have a great rest of
your day you too thanks man